Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
today President Biden
kicked off his European tour
in the U.K.
and met with British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson.
Yeah, at first, Biden didn't
even recognize Johnson.
He thought he was
a hungover Weasley brother.
[ Laughter ]
But Biden and Johnson
are getting a lot done.
Today, they launched
a task force to reopen travel
between the US and the UK.
When they heard that,
Harry and Meghan were like,
"You can try all you want..."
That's right --
Biden and Johnson are trying
to reopen travel
between the US and the UK,
which is great because
it means we're one step closer
to Kamala Harris
finally visiting Europe.
-And I haven't been to Europe.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"I've never been there."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Biden and Johnson
were actually supposed to meet
on a small island before
bad weather changed their plans.
This is the island right there.
Yeah.
That's a shame because
I love it when world leaders
hang out at locations
from "Mario Kart."
[ Laughter ]
Did you see that cute island?
I mean, come on.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, if Putin invited you
to a place like that,
you'd be like, "Uh, let's do it
somewhere more public!
Uh, let's go to the M&M Store."
Yep, Biden and Johnson met at
the site of this weekend's G7,
and right across the street,
an artist built a sculpture
of the seven leaders
made out of electronic trash
and called it
"Mount Recyclemore."
Take a look at this thing.
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
It's kind of sad Trump
couldn't even get his face
on Mount Recyclemore.
You know?
Sad.
That's right.
President Biden spent
the whole day over in the UK.
And you know the British have
some pretty colorful slang,
but so does President Biden,
so we thought we would put
together a quick tutorial
on the differences between
how they use certain phrases.
For example, first up,
we have "slag off."
To someone in England, that
means "to criticize someone."
But for Biden, it means...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Put hot dogs in his pocket?
-Ew.
In the shirt pocket.
-Shirt pockets to keep you cool.
-Yeah, to keep you cool.
-Yeah. That's interesting.
-Not cooked.
-Let's look at another example.
We have "Bob's your uncle."
The British use that to mean
"and there you have it."
But to Biden...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I -- Squirting?
-Like that?
-Interesting.
-With holy water?
-Finally, we have
"throwing a wobbly."
To the British, it means
"having a tantrum."
But to Biden...
Just interesting.
Interesting difference.
Interesting.
[ Applause ]
Hey, this is cool.
I saw that Mattel just announced
its first line of Barbie dolls
made from recycled plastic.
That's great, but, honestly,
I feel like they could have done
a better job with the name.
Garbage Barbie. I just --
-That's not good.
-That's just odd.
-Yeah.
-Get this.
7-Eleven just announced
that this year,
their free Slurpee giveaway
will not just occur on one day,
but for the entire month
of July.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's part of their
94th-birthday celebration,
which means they're almost
as old as the hot dogs
on the rotating grill.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
this is very exciting.
Today Mayor de Blasio announced
that New York City is bringing
back the Macy's Fourth of July
Fireworks Show.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Of course,
the big fireworks show
will immediately be followed
by the Car Alarm Spectacular.
We have a great show.